[Music]
the mass shootings in Texas and Ohio add
to the country's grim record on gun
violence there have been at least 255
mass shootings this year they've killed
273 people and injured more than a
thousand others New York Police Deputy
Commissioner John Miller testified
before Congress in 2016 about law
enforcement support for new gun laws he
made reference to the 2012 Sandy Hook
elementary shooting some might have said
when they kill our kindergarten children
in their schools that that would be the
straw that broke the back but we've
talked about that for a while and
nothing happened there either you have
to ask yourself have we figured out who
we are and do we want to change so is
there new momentum for change after the
attacks in El Paso in Dayton John Miller
who's also our former senior
correspondent joins us now John welcome
back good to be here have you been
invited back to Capitol Hill by the way
since that I have been and and by the
chairman of that committee for the
unveiling of his portrait so it's a very
it's a very brittle and bipartisan issue
and the fact that we're still talking
about it like we can't fix it is strange
I want to ask you about this memo that
the FBI put out this weekend that they
remain concerned the us-based domestic
violent extremists could become inspired
by these in previous high-profile
attacks there were also two Criminal
Justice professors in the Los Angeles
Times this weekend who are studying mass
mass killings who said that that these
kinds of things are socially contagious
so yesterday bill Sweeney the assistant
director of the FBI in New York invited
us on to a national conference call with
DES about it's the FBI's deputy director
and one of the things he talked about
was the FBI doing a threat assessment
kind of a fresh look to look at is this
phenomenon a contagion and that's
because it's not because you had two
horrific incidents within 24 hours or
less it's because if we go over last
week starting with the Garlic Festival
in California there were four active
shooter situations
in the United States and this is now a
pace we haven't seen before so I think
you have to look at what is the role of
guns assault weapons high-capacity
magazines yeah the New York Post today
yes
has a headline ban assault weapons this
is a paper that's generally very
friendly to President Trump very and and
I think when you look at that number of
things changing sentiments you also have
to look at these offenders there's a
question here you had andre simmons on
where jeffrey gaze a couple of minutes
ago or one of the best profilers from
the best profiling unit in the world and
and what they will tell you is one
doesn't make the next shooter think of
i'll do that to one one makes the next
person who's already thinking about it
accelerate their plans and when you have
a mix of workplace violence political
agendas a underpinning of mental health
but as andre pointed out that's
primarily mental health problems well
it's all identified was only medically
diagnosed in a quarter of the cases what
you see here though is a phenomenon
where we and here on television there's
a distinctive role in it have given
people a chance to rewrite their life
histories the stressors are i got thrown
out of school I lost my apartment I'm
not making it work I got fired from my
job I got dumped by a girlfriend now in
half of these cases there are four of
these stressors or more then they say
well I'm not going to be defined this
way I'm going to rewrite my story I'm
gonna go out literally with a bang I'm
gonna take a lot of people with me you
know they have what they call a period
of grievance identification where they
decide whose fault all their problems
are and target that place or those
people often a specific individual
sometimes you know a name target first
and then everybody else who is there and
John when you're talking about this I'm
sorry to interrupt but you're all these
factors that are out there for the FBI
or any other group to investigate that
when you talk in terms of domestic
terrorism versus international terrorism
is it different or do you have the same
tools and resources well what we're
seeing is a crossover a growing
crossover between mental health themes
political themes and terrorist themes
well
right wing and other extremism so if
somebody says I'm gonna do something in
the name of al-qaeda well if you get on
to that early that's material support of
an FTO foreign designated terrorist
organization there is no there are no
domestically designated terrorist
organizations that covers that as people
watch this you know time after time we
do these stories we hear the grief from
families from friends what can people do
if anything cuz I mean you even hear
from the friend and Dayton said he
seemed like a regular guy to me okay so
that's a great question because if you
look at if you look at the offender
characteristics eighty-three percent
let's think about that percentage
eighty-three percent of these offenders
have what they call leakage and that
means in the days and typically the
weeks before they start to say these
things to people around them educators
peers fellow employees tipping and
queuing of what's coming up you're not
gonna see me around soon everybody's
gonna learn what this was all about you
know they'll be sorry and you have to
kind of combine that with what do I know
about this person and should I be
concerned only a small percentage of
people actually contact authorities
about that some confront the person
directly and say what are you talking
about but half do nothing and that's
something that certainly has to change
John thank you for the time and the
insight we appreciate it thanks for
having me yeah